مسلسل رساله الامام بيتناول رساله الامام
محمد بن ادريس الشافعي في اخر 6 سنوات من
حياته اللي قضاها في مصر المسلسل من اكثر
الاعمال اللي كانت منتظره واللي ماخذه
متابعه واصداء من وقت ما بدا عرضه المسلسل
من امس متصدر الترند والمنصات والى جانب
المشاهد او المشاهده والمتابعه للمسلسل
المسلسل كمان عامل جدل وازمه والسبب اولا
موضوع بنسمعوه دائما في اي اعمال من اعمال
السيره الذاتيه اللي هي قصه الاخطاء
التاريخيه والحقائق والتفاصيل مثلا مثل
قصه استعانه الامام بطبيب لزوجته انه كان
يلبس نظاره وانه في اخطاء في اللغه
العربيه هذا غير اخطاء تاريخيه وصفها
البعض بالكارثيه الجدل من ليل ام زاد
يشتعل بعد مشهد طلع في الامام الشافعي
اللي بيقوم بدوره الفنان خالد النبوي طلع
بيتكلم بالعاميه المصريه وهنا الانتقادات
والجدل الضعف واتساءلوا عن ظهور العاميه
فجاه وقيل انه اللهجه هذه ما كانت موجوده
هذيك الايام اصلا
موضوع ثاني مشاهدينا بخصوص المسلسل العام
الجدل وهو الاقوال والحكم اللي بيقولها
فالشافعي معروف انه من اكثر الناس
المتداول لها اقوال وحكم واشعار كل بلاغه
ودروس في الحياه وهو كمان من اكثر الناس
اللي بتنسب له اقوي الماثوره مو قايلها
اصلا واليوم مع المسلسل في ناس بدات تعلق
قلقانه انه تبدا الناس تخلط بين الكلام
اللي قالوا الشافعي حقيقه وبين الكلام
اللي هو جزء من السيناريو والحوار الدرامي
للمسلسل واللي ما له علاقه بالامام
الشافعي في الحقيقه ولكن احقاقا للحق في
ناس عاجبها المسلسل جدا وبتمدح فيه جدا
وشايفه انه في او ماخذ حتى لوحده وما
بينافس احد ومستمتعين بمتابعته لاقصى درجه